[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVID BARRY: Well,
today at Google,
we're delighted to welcome
Mr. Erik Malinowski.
Mr. Malinowski is a sports
and features writer based out
of the Bay Area and has written
pieces for such publications
as "Wired," "Rolling
Stone," "Slate,"
and "The New Republic."
He was a reporter for
Bleacher Report, where
he covered the Golden
State Warriors,
and he is also a frequent
guest on NPR'S "Only a Game."
He has been recognized three
times by Best American Sports
Writing, which is an
annually published anthology
of the finest sports
journalism in the US.
He's here today to discuss
his new book, "Betaball--
How Silicon Valley Built One
of the Greatest Basketball
Teams in History."
Please join me in welcoming
to Google Mr. Erik Malinowski.
[APPLAUSE]
ERIK MALINOWSKI:
Thanks for having me.
DAVID BARRY: Yeah,
thank you for coming.
So I think I'd like
to start with maybe
a quick reading from the book.
ERIK MALINOWSKI: Sure.
DAVID BARRY: I think you
mentioned Google once or twice
in there.
ERIK MALINOWSKI: Yeah.
There's a couple of
Google references
sprinkled throughout the book,
so we'll do a blind read here.
We'll see-- and then we'll
do a quiz at the end.
DAVID BARRY: OK.
ERIK MALINOWSKI: So see
if you can think about who
would be saying this quote.
So a little back
story here-- so this
is the setup to
Kevin Durant, when
he signed with the Warriors
on July 4th of last year.
So this is a reference to the
backlash that was building up
in the wake of that.
Quote, "Nobody complains when
somebody leaves Apple and goes
to Google.
Aren't they in competition
with each other?
Nobody talk junk about the
CEO, who leaves Apple and goes
to Google.
As a basketball player, you
are the CEO of a business.
You are a business.
Kevin Durant is a big business.
He is the CEO of that business.
So him going to play basketball
for a different team, the CEO
decided to leave where he
was at and go somewhere else.
But there's so many guys in
this league that are so stupid,
they don't think like that.
They don't think business-wise.
It happens everyday
in the world.
But in basketball,
it's a problem.
Aren't you competitive in your
day job if you work for Apple?
Don't you want to outdo Google?
What's the difference
on the basketball court?
It's your day job.
You want to do what's
better for you."
OK, so do we think that
Joe Lacob, the owner
of the Warriors, said that,
who is a Silicon Valley venture
capitalist for 25 years?
Do we think that Rick
Welts, the team president
might have said that,
or Steve Kerr, the head
coach of the Warriors?
Or do we think,
perhaps, that was
Draymond Green who said that?
Obviously, just the fact that
we're asking this question,
it was Draymond
Green who said that.
But I like that quote, and
that's a quote, obviously,
that pops up at the
end of the book,
because the book is written
sort of chronologically,
and that's a recent event.
But I like that,
because it serves
as a nice bookend to
kind of what you've
read throughout the book
to that point, which
is that the Warriors are--
they are a different
kind of organization.
And the players and the
executives in the front office
here, they think and they talk
in a different kind of way,
and they approach not just
the game in another way,
but sort of the fundamentals
of the sport and the way
that they approach free
agency and their image
and all those other sort
of extracurriculars.
They look at the whole
package, and they approach it
in a different way
that I don't think
you get to see in a lot
of other organizations.
And that's a
representative of what
they've spent years trying
to build up the culture here
with the Warriors.
DAVID BARRY: And I think as you
mentioned throughout the book
sort of parallels with sort
of the Silicon Valley ethos
and the culture of the team.
And I think there's a lot of
parallels with Google as well.
ERIK MALINOWSKI: Right.
Yeah.
It's about empowering
your employees.
It's about-- it's really one of
the major themes of the book is
this idea that you
never really know
where the next good idea
is going to come from.
You might have a lot
of different people
in the room,
different paygrades.
Maybe some people's
office has a window.
Maybe some don't.
But you know, you don't
necessarily feel intimidated.
You understand that
you're all there invested
in a common problem,
and the bottom line
is you're all there to solve it.
And so someone might
have a good idea.
They might feel empowered
power to bring that up.
And the fact of the
matter is that there's not
a lot of organizations
in the NBA
that embrace that
sort of philosophy.
And that was something that,
when the new ownership came
in in the summer of
2010, they realized
that we don't have a whole
lot to lose basketball-wise.
And so they had a lot to lose
financially, because they
had paid a record sum of money.
They had paid $450
million, which was--
even though we just
had the Houston Rockets
sell for $2.2 billion, 450--
that was a record
sum, even though it
was only seven years ago.
So they came in, and they
realized, maybe financially we
have a lot to lose,
but basketball-wise, we
have an opportunity to basically
strip this organization down
to its bare bones.
And we're going to
rebuild it, and we're
going to operate it sort of as
if you would a Silicon Valley
startup.
And we're going to imbue it with
some of those same philosophies
and principles, basically
that Joe Lacob helped
do in his quarter century
working in the Valley.
DAVID BARRY: OK well, that's
a perfect segue, then.
So let's talk about where the
idea of betaball originated,
and could you explain,
maybe for people,
for the audience who
don't know, the title?
ERIK MALINOWSKI: Sure.
DAVID BARRY: And
sort of the product.
ERIK MALINOWSKI: So you
know, obviously, it's
a direct reference to that stage
of software development called
beta, where your final product
is not fully baked yet.
And so you are in a position,
where you can still innovate.
You can still change
some things up.
You can still-- you're
basically not afraid to fail.
You shouldn't be
afraid to take risks.
There could be a big
payoff in the end for you.
And so this was--
when I started writing
the proposal about a year
and a half ago,
maybe 20 months ago,
this was a case,
where I was trying
to take sort of a
very macro overview
and look at not just what the
Warriors had accomplished.
I mean, that was something I
wanted to get into the book,
but I wanted to get
into this larger
question of how they were able
to accomplish this thing that--
not just that not a lot
of other organizations
can reach this level of
success, but the fact
that we were seeing
unprecedented levels
of success.
You know, we've seen
historically great teams,
but the Warriors have
literally been doing things
that we've never seen before
in not just the modern NBA,
but in the entire NBA's history.
And then the real
brainstorm came--
Peter Guber was giving a
lecture down at Stanford.
They have their Sports
Innovation Conference
every March.
And he said something
to the effect of,
we are operating in a
constant state of beta.
And I sort of had all of these
ideas kicking around my brain
at that point, and
I realized that
that really was sort of
the connective tissue
here was that they've
been in a position
where they have-- they've tried
to stay nimble over the years.
They've made decisions that
have been controversial.
They've made a lot
of mistakes, but they
were in a position, where
they were going to learn
from them pretty quickly.
But at the same time, they
saw that this was also,
in a sense, a kind of
market inefficiency
that they could exploit, that
no other NBA teams were really
being run like this.
They were teams that had sort of
embraced technology and science
to a point.
But they were going
to go all out,
and they were going to basically
rebuild the entire organization
with these sort of
principles in mind.
It was sort of a case study.
And if they failed,
in some ways,
they were going to
fail spectacularly.
But this was something
that they set out to do,
and they were determined
to see it through its end.
They thought they
would be successful.
I don't think anybody
reasonably thought
that they would not just
turn it around in five years,
but create a
championship-winning team,
create something that was going
to compete for championships
year in and year out.
But obviously, they've
had some good fortune
and some serendipity
over the years.
But at the same
time, they've also
done a good job of
putting themselves
in a position to embrace
that and to take that
to its fullest potential.
And that is a direct
result of the principles
and the decisions that they've
instituted over the years.
So that's a lot of what I
get into the book, not just
the basketball
sense, but seeing how
a lot of the off-court stuff has
affected the basketball side.
DAVID BARRY: And it
sounds like, in the book,
for as nimble as they are,
Joe Lacob, in the beginning,
said he didn't want to come
in and make any changes that
were too drastic.
ERIK MALINOWSKI: Right.
Right.
DAVID BARRY: So it
sounds like in addition
to sort of being in this
continuous beta stage,
he also kind brings a
sort of wiser business,
you know, I guess
experience to the team.
Do you have anything to say--
ERIK MALINOWSKI: Yeah, I
mean this was something
that with sports fans,
you have to understand
that the Warriors were a
historically dreadful team.
I mean really, really bad.
They had-- when the
new ownership came in,
they had not made the
playoffs in 16 out of 17 years
preceding that.
And it's really hard to not
make the playoffs in the NBA.
Like literally, a majority of
the teams in each conference
make the playoffs every year.
So it almost requires a
certain perverse kind of effort
to be that bad in some
ways, or it's just
an extraordinarily amount
of bad luck or incompetence.
And I think it was all of
those things for the Warriors.
But when the new
ownership came in,
they decided that, yeah, they
were going to do it their way.
But they made a lot of mistakes
those first couple of years.
They had a lot to dig
out from, but there
was a little bit of a fan
revolt there at a couple
of times along the way.
So they were not
stubborn, but they
were determined to see it
through to a certain point.
But yeah, they decided
that we're just
going to try to put ourselves
in the best position
to try to succeed.
And there were
times along the way,
where they didn't know
which direction it
was going to go in.
And it wasn't a foregone
conclusion at any point
that they were going to
succeed to this level.
But they kept at it, and
they had some good fortune
along the way.
But they also had
the opportunity
to embrace all of that.
DAVID BARRY: I want to
dive in a little deeper
to what you mean
when you say that it
was Silicon Valley and
science that built this team.
ERIK MALINOWSKI: Yeah, it was--
so I mean, as a way
of going into that,
I'll say my reporting on
the Warriors goes back--
I've gotten to cover this team
pretty closely the last three
years or so.
But my reporting
really starts with them
back in the spring of 2011,
when the new owners had just
come in.
They had just been approved
in November of 2010,
so they were about three or four
months basically on the job.
And I did a story
for "Wired" about how
they were one of
the first few teams
in the league to adopt these--
to install these
motion tracking cameras
that we know in the
NBA today as Sport View
and has pretty much changed
the way that we write
about basketball, that
we understand the game,
all sorts of things
that we never thought
would be quantifiable before.
But back then, it was this
very nascent technology.
It was very new, and so I think
the analytically driven teams,
such as such as the
Houston Rockets,
who are led by Darrell
Morey, an MIT grad,
the co-founder of the
Sloan Sports Conference,
San Antonio Spurs have always
been analytically driven,
Oklahoma City Thunder, and
the Dallas Mavericks with Mark
Cuban and everything-- those
are teams that were the first
signatories on that,
and they always--
so those were the
teams you would expect.
The Warriors were the fifth
team to adopt Sport View,
and when I read about that--
I read about it
in the newspaper--
I was really surprised, because
that was just not something
that you associated
with this team.
But it was a very clear idea.
It was a very clear indication
that they were embracing
the geography, that they were
embracing the fact that Silicon
Valley was in their
backyard, that it
was very obvious you could see
then that Joe Lacob was going
to use his roots as
a venture capitalist
and try to learn from what
he learned from 25 years
being around these
sorts of companies.
And the people
working on Sport View
were-- it was all right here.
It was very local.
So I wrote that story,
and the basic premise
was that maybe they're
going to turn this around.
Maybe it's going to give
them a chance to maybe become
a mediocre team.
Maybe they can get out
of the bottom of the NBA.
And that was part of it,
but it was also this idea
that we're going to
hire the right people.
We're going to
bring in people that
have sort of a different
kind of experience
and a different background.
I look at someone
like, for example,
hiring Bob Myers as
assistant general manager.
This was also literally
the day that I
visited Oracle Arena
to see the cameras
and was walking on the catwalks
80 feet above the court.
It was later that
day that news had
leaked that they were
hiring a player agent named
Bob Myers to work in
their front office
and basically to groom this guy
to be the next general manager.
And there were a lot of
people around the NBA
that scoffed at this idea,
and they thought, well,
he doesn't have the
right kind of experience.
He's never worked
in a front office,
and the Warriors looked at
that, and their thinking
was a little more lateral,
and they thought, well,
15 years of experience at
the negotiating table--
that's 15 years of experience
at the negotiating table.
Sure, maybe he's on the
other side of the table,
but in some sense, it's
all of the same thing.
And maybe this is something
that other people are not
appreciating, or
they're overlooking.
This is a guy who
knows the agents,
having worked alongside them.
He knows the players, having
literally represented them.
This is a guy that-- this is
a new kind of NBA executive.
So it's that sort of [INAUDIBLE]
thinking and thinking,
this is a guy who has
maybe a different set
of core strengths, and we need
to bring this guy on our team.
And so bringing him
in, he was the guy
who signed Andre Iguodala.
It was literally through
his sheer efforts.
And I would say not
by having to convince
Andrea Iguodala to come
to the Warriors-- he
wanted to come here.
But Bob Myers had
to dump $24 million
in contracts, and
so in some ways,
who better to do that than
a former player agent who
understands the collective
bargaining agreement, who
understands the
intricacies of contracts,
and who knows the teams out
there who would be willing--
who have the
executives in place who
would be willing to
take on those contracts?
And then even just
to the present day,
look at signing Kevin Durant.
It was through Bob, it was
through his connections
and through just his sheer
energy and force of will
that allowed that to happen.
So there's not a
lot of organizations
that would've brought
in a guy like Bob Myers.
Yeah, a lot would
have wanted to bring
in a guy like Jerry West,
who the Warriors did,
and things like that.
But I sort of look specifically
at a hire like Bob Myers,
and I think, that
is a thing that
is indicative of a
specific kind of mindset.
And so this idea that
you're going to-- you've
got weaknesses on your
team and strengths,
and you're not going to bring
in just basically the most
talented or the
most experienced.
But you're going to
bring in people who have
a specific kind of experience.
And you're going to
use their strengths
to make up for the
weaknesses, perhaps,
of other people on the team.
And I think that is sort of
a very sort of Silicon Valley
mindset, where you want to
bring in people who have
all these varied experiences.
And you want this to be the
sort of perfect little brew,
where everyone is sort
of working in concert,
and people are lifting each
other up and all that sort
of thing.
And this is a thing that has
sort of been anathema to NBA
front offices over the years.
But the Warriors figured
that this was something
that we can apply to
running a basketball team.
DAVID BARRY: The idea
of bringing together
an eclectic board, who can
bring value in different ways.
ERIK MALINOWSKI: Yeah.
DAVID BARRY: And
also, I think it's
kind of a Silicon Valley idea--
you said that they were the
fifth team to use data science.
But you say throughout the book
how they weren't really looking
for a short-term payoff
with it, that they
knew it wasn't going to
pay off for a long time,
yet they continued to
make the investment.
ERIK MALINOWSKI: Yeah.
They were-- what they
were doing was so new
and so nascent at that
point, and the technology
itself was so
immature in some ways,
that they had the
presence of mind
that they were going to spend
a not insignificant amount
of money installing these
cameras, and then in time,
hiring people to interpret this
data in such a way that would
befit the basketball team.
But all of that
took a long time,
and at the very
beginning, they did not
have a head coach in place.
Keith Smart, who was very
receptive to all of that--
in fairness, not even the
next head coach they hired,
Mark Jackson, was all
that receptive to it.
But by that time, they were
in a position, where they
were hiring these analysts.
They were bringing people
into their front office
that could interpret
the data in such a way.
And I should say, also,
that this was really
only six years ago we're
basically talking about.
They're actually--
I mean they're
just weren't even
a lot of people
in the industry that were
well-versed in this sort
of thing.
They had to look at, who
were the people that they
were going to be up and
coming in this industry?
Who were the people
that might be
a general manager in 10 years?
But they're taking sort of
a different career path.
You It's very much something
like in "Moneyball,"
with Michael Lewis, you
know, he talks about,
obviously, "Moneyball"
is all about Billy Beane,
but one of the secondary stars
of that book is Paul DePodesta.
And so basically, what
the Warriors were doing
is, who is our Paul DePodesta?
Who are the people that are
younger but are coming up
and are native in
this sort of language
and these sorts of skills?
And so it was about--
they were in a position, where
Joe Lacob's son, Kirk Lacob,
was a Stanford graduate.
And he was actually friends
with a lot of these guys
that are working on these
tech initiatives that
could be applied to
basketball in a certain way.
And so in some ways, they
were fortunate to have
Kirk Lacob in a
position, where he
can bring in some of these guys
and introduce them to the team.
But it's also about hiring a
guy like Sammy Gelfand, who
came up--
he was a DC guy and came
up through the D-league
and was working as an analyst.
And this was a guy, as you're
reading the book, Kirk Lacob
and Sammy Gelfand,
they basically
formed this bond,
this friendship,
and Sammy is one of these
guys now that comes up.
And now to this day,
he's the number two
guy at the Warriors in
the analytics department,
but this is a guy who was
hired, in a lot of ways,
not just to crunch numbers
but to be that liaison,
to be that guy who can
act as a go-between
between the analytics department
and the coaching staff,
and then, in turn, the players,
because the Warriors realized
early on, even if they were
aggregating all this data, even
if they didn't necessarily
know when they were going
to be able to use it in
a basketball kind of way,
that when it came
time to do that,
that you could have the
best analytics in the world.
But if you don't have people
in place, who are going to--
that can convey that
information in a way that
makes sense, that can apply
that in a basketball sense
and go to these coaches, go to
these players, and say, look,
I know that you're used to
doing things in a certain way.
But this-- go work
with us on this.
This is going to help you
play basketball in a way
that maybe you've
never played it before.
This is going to help you
find a level of success
that you've never found before.
Then, the best analytics
don't mean anything,
if you don't have the people
that can explain those concepts
and actually will work to
convince people of their value.
Then, it's almost
all for nothing.
So this is really just about all
these pieces coming together.
And like you said, the
investment in time,
not just in money, but
in time, and to know
that there would come
a day, and maybe it
was in two years or three
years or four years,
but that all of this stuff was,
in a sense, going to pay off,
and maybe was going to pay off
big time, maybe a little bit,
but to stay with
that investment,
and to understand that this is
working toward something bigger
and better in time.
DAVID BARRY: And it sounds like
Steve Kerr is a perfect example
of that in terms of
understanding the analytics,
but also knowing how
to get stuff done.
But let's postpone
that for a second.
ERIK MALINOWSKI: Sure, OK.
DAVID BARRY: So take us
back through the history,
for anyone in the audience
who may not be a Warriors fan,
didn't experience it as a fan.
What was the story
of the Warriors
before it got sold to
the current ownership?
ERIK MALINOWSKI: I
mean, it's been--
it is a varied and
eclectic history.
And they are not just one of
the oldest teams in the NBA.
I mean the Warriors
actually predate the NBA.
They were one of
the teams-- they
were one of the franchises
that merged with another league
and essentially created
the NBA in 1949, I believe.
But they found a lot
of success early on.
They've had historically
great players
like Wilt Chamberlain
and Nate Thurman
and Rick Barry over the years.
And they were really good in
the mid-'70s, also the time that
the Oakland As were winning the
World Series across the walkway
from them.
The Warriors were winning
championships in Oakland Arena,
but this was a
team that when they
head into the '80s
and early '90s,
success was few and far between.
This was a team that, in
time, became historically bad
on a level that we've
almost never seen before.
A lot of that had to do with
the new owner, Chris Cohan,
coming in 1995.
He had been a minority
owner with the Warriors.
He had come into the Warriors in
some little bit of shady means,
and then in even
shadier means, managed
to become the full 100% owner
of the Warriors in 1995.
But this was a guy that was
so incredibly incompetent,
and he was a cable TV magnate.
He had founded and run
Sonic Communications.
But he was not a basketball guy.
He brought in guys
to run the team that
were not basketball guys.
They were just guys that he
had known through his college
connections down
in San Luis Obispo.
And so it's no surprise
that just year after year,
they would pass on--
I spell this out in
the book, but they
passed on just one Hall
of Famer after another.
Obviously, hindsight's
20/20, but you
would think at some point, you
would hit on one of these guys.
But obviously, I think
the big one is drafting
Todd Fuller, instead
of Kobe Bryant,
I think is sort of the
one that most Warriors
fans bemoan the most.
But they would have these blips
of success over the years.
They had, for example, the
We Believe season in 2006
and '07, but just as fast
as that success came around,
it would sort of go away,
and it was so fleeting.
So by the time the Cohan
decided to sell the team,
I mean at that point,
it almost didn't even
matter who they were sold to.
They were going to--
Warriors fans were
going to be elated.
But you talked
earlier about sort
of waiting a little while
to turn the team around.
That was one of the
reasons why the fans--
the honeymoon period with
this new ownership group
was so quick, because
they do expect, especially
when you've had 15 years of
failure, almost concurrently,
but this idea that you're
going to clean house.
You're going to-- it doesn't
matter who you bring in,
but you're going to get
rid of all these guys
that had all this failure.
And they didn't do that.
They waited six months.
They brought a startup
kind of mindset,
where it's like, we're
going to evaluate everyone's
place in this company.
And maybe there are
some hidden gems here.
We don't know that.
If we just come in here
and clean house and act
sort of irrationally,
you could say,
we might be throwing
out some people that
could be some valued members.
It doesn't mean everyone's bad.
It just means that a
lot of them are bad,
but we need to take
the time, and we
to invest in the sort
of evaluation process.
And there were guys,
there were holdovers.
There was a-- the
Atlanta Hawks just hired
a guy named Travis Schlenk.
He was actually the
guy that I went up
in the catwalks over Oracle
Arena with back in 2011.
But he had been
with the Warriors.
He was a coach, and
then an executive,
but he had been in
the Chris Cohan era
for six, seven, eight years.
And he was the guy
that they kept around,
because they looked
at his place,
and they saw he had a
specific set of skills.
He was a guy that was
well-versed in the draft
and player evaluation,
and it wasn't his fault
that they weren't drafting Kobe
Bryant and Vince Carter and all
these other guys.
But this was a guy that
we needed to stick around,
and so they did that.
It was pretty methodical,
but they took their time.
And in addition to trying
to change the culture,
it was about identifying, who do
they already have around here?
And so that gave them a
little bit of a head start,
but obviously, they still
had all of this work
to do going forward.
DAVID BARRY: It
sounded a little bit
like the movie,
"Office Space," where
they bring in the consulting
firm to give everyone
the chance to show their worth.
ERIK MALINOWSKI: Yes, I think
it was a little bit of that.
It was a little more high--
I mean, in addition to
all that, they also spent
almost $2 million renovating the
actual offices of the Warriors.
They walked in there, and
they realized that not only
is this culture of failure--
it's not just on the
basketball court.
It's in the workplace.
And so they realized
that people did not
enjoy coming to work every day.
They didn't have
pride in the team.
That's one of the things
I say in the book is
that if they're going to sell
the Warriors as this free agent
destination to sell it to
other players in the NBA,
they basically had to sell the
Warriors to their own employees
first.
That pride in the work
that they were doing
was just, basically,
nonexistent.
So they knocked
down cubicle walls,
and they built
these new workspaces
to try to increase
cross-collaboration and trust
with each other, and not just
bring in the right people,
but to just change the culture
and change the workspace
and things like that.
And that's what I've seen
really take root over the years
is that, especially with the
players that they brought in,
but also talking to
front office execs,
but especially with
the players, it's
this idea that they use
language that I've never
heard other professional
athletes use before.
They say things like,
I like coming to work,
coming into work today.
You I like-- this is my job.
I like my job.
And this is not something
that we, I think,
associate with
professional athletes,
but just to sort of hear
the way that they like--
and I think,
obviously, some of this
is all the success they have.
And obviously, the
more success you have,
the more you want
to come into work,
whether that's
sports or a business
or something like that.
But that's a peek
into the mindset
of how the Warriors operate is
that that's how they view it.
They don't view it as
coming into play basketball.
They view it as
coming in to do a job.
Everyone has a job to do, and
the court is your workplace,
and the practice court
is your workplace.
And at the day is
done, you go home.
You do non-basketball
things and other things,
and you come, and you
do the basketball,
and everything is valued.
And that's just not something
that you see across the NBA,
but it's something
that the Warriors--
they hold that in high esteem.
DAVID BARRY: Yeah, and on the
opposite end of the spectrum,
I think you mentioned the
Latrell Sprewell incident.
ERIK MALINOWSKI: That
was sort of a low point.
DAVID BARRY: Yeah.
ERIK MALINOWSKI: Yeah.
DAVID BARRY: OK, great.
So there's a lot of
talk right now about how
the Warriors are
fundamentally changing
the way the game is played.
What do you make of that,
and how revolutionary
has it really been?
ERIK MALINOWSKI:
I mean, it's not
like the Warriors are the ones
that came up with the idea
that, oh, we should shoot
a bunch of three-pointers,
and this is how we're going
to score our way to success.
There have been-- you look
at like Doug Moes, the Denver
Nuggets team of the
early '80s, where
they would score 120 points a
game or something like that.
Or you look at Mike D'Antoni,
Suns, the "07 Seconds or Less"
Suns, Jack McCallum's
famous book.
But especially, this is a lot
of stuff that has taken root--
Mark Jackson, I think, laid the
foundation for a lot of this,
and that's something I get
into the book is that he's
a guy that came in and gave
them a lot of confidence
and proved that you could have
a winning formula by shooting
the three ball, and that this
was a way that you could find--
you could basically take the
team from these low depths
and excel into something
bigger than that.
But when Steve Kerr came in, it
was this idea that not only can
we score in bunches.
We can embrace the
three-point shot,
even in ways that take it,
what the Mark Jackson was doing
and kick it up a
couple of notches.
But we can also play
defense at the same time.
And this was-- you look at the
metrics over the last three
years, so when Steve Kerr
has become head coach.
We've never seen a team in
NBA history that has played,
that has had such an
efficient offense,
but has not sacrificed
defense in such a way.
And what Steve Kerr came
in and was able to do
was that he showed
the guys that now you
can keep shooting threes.
You can keep scoring in
bunches, but if we also
commit on the defensive
end, your offense
is going to be more efficient
than it has ever been,
because you get stops.
You get rebounds.
The other team is
out of position.
You run the fast break, or
you pop back out for a three.
You catch guys out of position.
There's all sorts of ways
that you can use defense
to make your offense better.
And you just look
at the numbers,
and we've never
seen a team excel
on both ends of
the court the way
we've seen with the Warriors.
And so they're showing,
in a way, that you can--
it's not just live
and die by the three,
but it's thrive by the three.
And at the same time,
if you are committed
to defense in such a way,
you can be better off for it
on both ends of the court.
So they value both
of those things.
For as long as Steve
Kerr is the head coach,
if they are ever
lower than top five
in defense, that's a year that
he's probably going to consider
a failure, because he just--
he values both
parts of that game.
But we talk about the
Warriors doing things
that no team has ever done
and shaking the very core
of the foundations of the NBA.
This is one of those
examples, because we've just
never seen it on
both ends the way
we've seen it with this team.
DAVID BARRY: Yeah, I think
the quintessential example is
rather than taking a layup, like
Steph Curry will forego a layup
to take a three, and
it's actually-- so
what's informed that strategy?
Was that a data analysis or?
ERIK MALINOWSKI: I
just think it's--
I think it's showing the
players that on some level,
it's pretty elementary.
It's convincing them that
three is worth more than two,
so we've got that part down.
We've got that technical math
part of the equation settled.
But it's the idea
that you're completely
capable of shooting
a three-point shot
and making it in
any given scenario.
And traditionally
in the NBA, it's
almost seems hubris
in some ways to--
you've got the easy
layup, or maybe you've
got one on one match-up.
You challenge the
guy at the rim,
and you go, you take it
up, and you take it strong.
You don't kick it out to the
trailer for a three pointer
when there's no one
within 12 feet of him,
and literally, everyone else
is trailing on the play,
but this guy's wide open.
But when that guy
is Steph Curry,
or that guy is Klay Thompson,
and you practice that play,
and they can do that in
rhythm, then the whole play
just feels natural to them.
And so you just make that
a part of your offense.
You make that a part of the
culture of how you play,
and then it just
becomes second nature.
Then it doesn't become
this hubristic display
of basketball.
Then it just becomes another
part of your game plan,
and boy, when you're an
opposing team, and now,
all of a sudden, that is
something that you need to game
plan for, now you
have the advantage.
Now, you have the
leg up on them,
because now you have
to keep them honest.
Now it's just not a
forgone conclusion
that you're going to be going
up strong for the layup.
Now you've got to
watch the trailer.
You're going to kick
it out to the guy,
and you have to be ready
for all sorts of scenarios.
DAVID BARRY: Right, so much more
frustrating for the defense.
ERIK MALINOWSKI: Well, not
for Warriors fans, but yes,
it's frustrating for
the opposing defense.
Exactly.
DAVID BARRY: OK, can you
talk about Steve Kerr?
What has he meant to the
team, and what could all of us
learn from his leadership style?
ERIK MALINOWSKI:
I mean it's hard--
it's sort of hard for me to
be objective about Steve Kerr.
He really is sort of one of my--
in all the years that I've been
covering sports and writing
about it, I mean he's pretty
much one of my favorite people.
He's so-- I mean he's
just a genuine guy.
What you see is what
you get, but he's
had such incredible and
varied life experiences.
Coming up through Arizona,
very public-- his father
was a diplomat in
the Middle East.
His father was
assassinated in 1984, back
when he was still a
freshman at Arizona.
And he just became this national
name that everybody knew about,
and it was almost
about that same time
that he just really
started to find himself
as a basketball
player, as a person,
and just worked his way up.
This is a guy that
really had no right--
6'3", 171, know what I mean?
He had a little bit--
he just didn't
have-- he's not what
you sort of thought of as this
star college basketball player.
But just through this force
of sheer will, confidence,
cockiness, whatever you want to
call it, just this exuberance,
he was able to-- he
became this national star
and worked his way, basically,
into a 15-year NBA career that
was almost one of the most
inexplicable careers just
in terms of his physicality and
what he brought to the game.
But he came up through
the NBA in college.
It was literally while he was
in college that the NCAA adopted
the three-point shot.
And so when he got to the
NBA a couple years later,
this was a time when
the three-point shot
was coming into vogue.
It had been in the NBA for
a few years at that point,
but finally, the NBA
was embracing the idea
of a three-point specialist.
And so I think he started, or he
played something like 900 games
across his NBA career.
But I think when he
only started like 10.
He was this super sixth man
sub, but that was his role,
and he understood that.
He was a team player, but
also at the same time,
he won five championships
as a player.
On a Chicago Bulls team
that had Michael Jordan,
he hit a game-winning shot
to win a championship.
Michael Jordan passed to Steve
Kerr to win a championship,
and I think that,
in some ways, that's
something that sort of
people forget about.
But at the same
time, this is a guy
that's always understood that
basketball has its place.
I think it's probably because
all the personal stuff that's
gone on with him.
He understands that
basketball-- there's this
saying "basketball is life."
Well, to him, basketball
is very much not life.
There is so much
more to basketball,
and all of those things
need to be balanced.
It's about happiness.
It's about doing
what's right for you.
It's about understanding that
basketball has its place,
but there's so much more
to experience in life--
not to jump ahead, but I
think that's why you've seen
him be such a vocal critic.
He's been involved in this
current administration, things
like that.
A lot of that you see is
manifested in this idea
that there is so much more
to life than just basketball,
but when they hired him
in the summer of 2014,
this was a case, where
the timing was right.
He was in a position, where
he had been a general manager
before the NBA.
It had gone pretty
wrong with Phoenix.
They had some success,
but that team--
it ended pretty badly.
But he had been a broadcaster
a couple of times,
but he was in a position
where his kids were older.
He was looking for
a new challenge.
I think he'd always wanted
to get into coaching,
but this was a guy--
he had had a heck
of a head start.
The Warriors had won 51
games under Mark Jackson,
and it was a lot of pressure.
Whoever was going
to replace him,
there were a lot of very good
reasons why Mark Jackson--
why his tenure came to
an end as Warriors coach.
But this was a guy
with the weight
of the world on his
shoulders, and I
think there were
a lot of coaches
that might've come
into that situation
and realized that it might
have gone really badly.
They had all this talent.
There was all
these expectations.
They thought maybe it was the
germ of sort of a championship
level team here, but he came
in and it was a position where
he had some very
certain ideas and things
that he wanted to institute, and
so he just set about doing it.
And it was a very-- he
fit in really perfectly,
I think, with the culture
that we had seen here.
But they had some
really tough decisions
to make right off
the bat as soon
as he came in as head coach.
One of those was
this idea that, oh,
whether or not they
should trade away
Klay Thompson for Kevin Love.
So this was--
I think he'd only been on the
job for about a month or so,
and the Minnesota
Timberwolves come
to the Warriors and
this idea that we're
going to offer Kevin
Love for Klay Thompson.
That was basically the
centerpiece of the package.
This was something
a lot of people--
there were a lot
of Warriors fans
that thought this was
kind of a no-brainer.
Kevin Love could
shoot the three ball.
He was taller.
He wasn't a defensive upgrade.
I think they were a little
bit of a wash in that regard,
but this idea that
Steve Kerr is coming in.
He's going to institute this new
kind of motion kind of offense.
Mark Jackson had a very sort
of traditional pick and roll
offense, that kind of thing,
script out these three-point
plays for Steph and Klay.
And with Steve Kerr, it was
going to be a little bit more
not improvisational,
but it was going
to be a little bit
more free-flowing.
It was going to be
more about spacing.
It was going to be more
about these plays that
were predicated on
timing, and the idea
was that somebody
like Kevin Love
might fit into that
a little bit better.
And so-- but this was one of the
big decisions they had to make.
And so it ended up,
as I read in the book,
that they had all these
guys in a room trying
to make the decision,
including Joe Lacob,
including Bob Meyers and top
management, this idea that,
are we going to
pull this trigger?
And so there were
a lot of people
in the room that wanted
to make that move,
but there were two voices
in that room that were
pretty staunchly against this.
And one of those was Jerry West,
who they brought in not to be
a decision-maker but
to be a guy who could--
he specifically did not want
to make those decisions.
He told them flat out.
But I can point you guys
in the right direction,
and you can value my counsel
or not if you want to.
So this was a case
where Jerry West was
speaking up and
saying, you guys,
I really think you
should stand pat.
You shall hold your ground.
Don't be enticed
by the idea here.
And the other guy
was Steve Kerr,
and he said, I like the
team that we have here.
I like the players
that are in here.
I don't think we need
to make this sort
of drastic bold kind of move.
And it was-- obviously,
it was Steve and Jerry
that sort of ruled the day.
Their voices carried
the most weight.
They were the most
persuasive, and Joe Lacob,
he's fine with that.
I mean he's a guy I think
that could have gone
either way on that,
but he chose to listen
to these guys' counsel.
And I'll just read a little bit.
DAVID BARRY: Yeah.
ERIK MALINOWSKI:
Something from the book,
something that he says sort of
directly in relation to that.
You know, Lacob says, "We
encourage very strong debate,
but then it's my job
to make the decision.
I certainly listen most of the
time to what the group decides,
and then we just
do it, and we go.
I do think that that
is what's different.
That's what separates us.
That's the Silicon Valley
way, the entrepreneur way.
That is not the
big company way."
And so I think that's really
sort of representative
of in that whole
anecdote, this whole idea
that it would have been
very easy to sort of bow
to the pressure, to
bow to the tantalizing
idea of bringing a
guy in with Kevin Love
and into this new offense.
I think it helped a lot that
one of the guys telling him
not to do it was Steve Kerr,
the guy who would eventually
have to coach him.
But it was this idea that we're
going to give everyone a voice.
We're going to try to look
at everything objectively,
and we're just going to try
to make the decision that's
best for our team.
We're not going to let any
of those external pressures
weigh on us.
We're going to try to
look at it in a very sort
of narrow, goal-oriented
and driven kind of way.
And again, sometimes--
I like that anecdote,
because it's not about--
sometimes it's not about the
decisions that you do make.
It's about the decisions
that you decide not to make.
And in this very
specific case, I
think history has sort of
validated their decision
not to make the decision.
DAVID BARRY: Absolutely.
And yeah, at Google,
we have a motto
having to do with the HiPPOs,
the highest paid person.
You Don't necessarily
just blindly follow them.
At least weigh the ideas
for their intrinsic value.
So it sounds like a
very similar situation.
So what do-- for the people in--
so what do Warriors
fans, like the die-hards,
they may not be season ticket
holders, but people who have
followed the team closely.
What can they take
away from the book?
ERIK MALINOWSKI: I think just
understand that we have--
so people that are season
ticket holders or not?
DAVID BARRY: No.
ERIK MALINOWSKI: They're
not season ticket holders.
DAVID BARRY: But
still very good fans.
ERIK MALINOWSKI: I think
that just this idea
that this whole ascent
has been so fast.
There's so much
that goes into it.
There's so much that goes into
building a team from scratch,
basically.
Even just through, I like--
this has been a pretty
ephemeral amount of time.
We're only talking
five, seven years--
five years of the
playoffs, seven years
since the new
ownership has come in.
But there's just so
much that goes into it.
There's so many little
decisions and machinations,
and there's so many
parts along this path.
It's a lot more
winding than linear,
but there's so many
parts, where it just all
could have gone terribly wrong.
None of this was--
this was no foregone
conclusion that these guys were
kind of good men,
and they were going
to institute these principles
and this new philosophy
and that it was going
to work out like this.
And at the same time, it's
not just a matter of-- it's
not just so reductive
as just saying,
oh, it's just because they
have a Steph Curry or a Klay
Thompson.
I think that's--
I mean I think there's
validity to that.
I don't discount the
importance of having talent.
Obviously, I think
talent, in some ways,
is the biggest part
of the equation.
But just the fact that
we are seeing a team--
I mean we've seen elite
teams before in the NBA,
but just that we're
seeing a team now
that has reached such--
I mean is literally doing things
every season that we've never
seen a team do before.
And then, also, now that we're
seeing teams sort of copy that
in such a way and trying
to not use that necessarily
as a blueprint for success, but
at least try to put themselves
in a position to take
advantage of the good fortune
or development curves the same
way that the Warriors have.
But just this idea that
they can read this book
and understand that it's a lot--
there's a lot more
complexity to it.
It's a lot more nuanced.
Obviously, having
a Steph and a Klay
and a Draymond and
a Kevin Durant,
obviously, that helps out a lot.
But there's really so much
more that goes into that,
and it really is not just
about what is on the court.
But it's about, what is
the front office doing?
What are the coaches doing?
What is everyone
in the organization
doing to help everyone
sort of play the best
basketball they can, be the best
kind of employee they can be?
And I feel like on some
levels, a lot of that stuff
would be relatable,
because I think we've all--
anyone's that had a job has
sort of found themselves
in that kind of
position, where they want
to be happy where they work.
They want to thrive.
They want their colleagues to
help pick them up when they're
down, that kind of thing.
And so I feel like
people read through it,
and it's like, yeah, I mean
I feel like they can kind
of relate to a lot of that.
DAVID BARRY: So a lot has been
made of the Warriors embracing
new tech and analytics to take
the team to the next level.
But in real terms, what
does that look like?
And how do they maintain their
advantage over other teams
in the league, who are
now trying to catch up?
ERIK MALINOWSKI:
I mean it's tough,
because like I
said, it was easier
in the beginning for
them, because they
were one of the first
signatories of Sport View.
And so it was pretty
easy in some ways
to see that that
was the direction
that the league was heading.
So at that point, it
was really just a matter
of investing the money, hiring
the right kind of people,
and then, I think,
in time, just sort
of hoping that it kind of
panned out to some extent.
It's become harder over
the years to do that,
because Sport View
is so ubiquitous now.
And every team has analysts.
Every team sends people to
the Sloan Sports Conference
every March in Boston,
so everyone sort of
understands a lot
of those things.
And so for the
Warriors especially,
trying to maintain
that edge, it's about--
I mean they've got
a lot in place,
because they have a
guy like Steve Kerr.
And more than Steve
Kerr, they have
he has hired
assistant coaches that
really understand these things.
Even you talk about old timers
like Ron Adams and people
like that that have
been around a long time,
but yet understand the value and
the importance of those things.
But for them, it's about trying
to find the next frontier.
It's about monitoring
sleep patterns.
It's about issuing personality
tests and things like that
and regular player
evaluations and not
judging all of these
things individually,
but trying to look at
them in their totality
and looking at that
and saying, what
sort of a picture of
my basketball team
are all of these different
criteria painting?
And how do I apply that
in a basketball sense?
And so they can understand
when guys might need a day off.
The term they use
is "redlining."
Are these guys getting
too close to the zone,
where they might suffer an
injury, that sort of thing?
I mean that really
is sort of the next--
and no one has really perfected
that part of the puzzle yet.
I mean, the next
frontier really is
sort of like injury
prevention in whatever
form that [INAUDIBLE] itself.
The worst thing,
I think, they've
got a lot of that figured
out in terms of monitoring
player fatigue and energy.
You can't do this
during the games yet,
and there's very
good reasons why,
and the collective
bargaining agreement
is very clear about
these sorts of things.
But they can monitor
these guys in practice,
and they can look at
the Sport View data
from the games
themselves, and they
can understand the amount of
dribbles that they're taking
or how fast-- literally,
how fast they're
running up and down the court.
And they can look at all
of these things in concert,
and they can say it's
about resting these guys.
It's about, who do we then put
in the lineup and that sort
of thing.
And to some extent, that's
really all you can do.
But it's about how far
you can drill down on that
and how many different
criteria you can all
bring into this equation.
So for them, I think it's
really the bottom line
is it's all about,
what new information
can we gather that
we're not gathering?
And then the second
step is, how do we apply
that in a basketball sense?
And so that's why they're
always looking to partner up
with these new third party
tech ventures and initiatives,
and they're always
willing to listen.
They're always willing
to have a conversation,
and not all of these
things pan out.
And they start partnerships,
and they end partnerships,
but I think they're
always looking--
again, because they
have the convenience,
they have the geography
on their side,
and they can work to take
advantage of these things that
I think that a lot of
other organizations can't.
So I think they're
cognizant of that advantage,
and I think they just
figured, we're just
going to use this to
our most advantage.
DAVID BARRY: It sounds
like similar data
is being employed for injury
prevention in other sports
as well.
Keith Law was here
recently and talked
about the sleeve that pitchers
are using now in baseball.
So on that note, what can
other NBA teams, but also teams
just in any sport--
what can they take away?
What can they learn
from the book?
ERIK MALINOWSKI: I
think a lot of it
is, again, this sort
of sounds obvious,
but it's not as ubiquitous
as you might think.
But it's really just about
listening to your athletes.
It's about in the same
place in the workplace,
it's about listening
to your employees
and valuing their opinion and
their place in the workplace.
But it's about understanding
what they're going through.
Everybody is different.
Everybody processes
information in a certain way.
Everyone fatigues in a certain
way in an athletic sense.
But understanding that
you're really only going
to be able to predict
these things as well as you
can talk to your
athletes, that you
can gain their trust,
that you can have
a dialogue about these things.
These are things that
the teams they thought
were unquantifiable,
or they would not
be able to discern anything
of any import from,
but I think what
we're understanding
is as these fields get
more mature, and more
is invested in them over time,
that there is a lot to learn,
that the athletes themselves
are really the best
source of this information.
And so if you can apply
that in a way that
works best for
your team, yeah, I
mean you can prevent injuries.
You can improve
team cohesiveness.
These are hard concepts for
a lot of teams to invest in,
because some of them are pretty
nebulous, or in some cases,
you're relying on
athletes' words.
You don't necessarily have
hard data to back it up.
But if you can combine
these things with the data
that you are
aggregating, I do think
you get a more fuller
understanding of the athlete
or your employee.
And just you can help
improve your workplace
in a lot of ways.
I think that on a foundational
level, a lot of these concepts
are-- they can be applied
in all sorts of ways.
DAVID BARRY: And taking a
lesson from the Warriors,
the first step might just
be collecting the data,
and then worrying
about the analysis.
ERIK MALINOWSKI: Yeah,
worry about it later,
but you have to be willing to
make that initial investment.
That's a leap of faith.
I mean that's not something
that a lot of organizations do,
and to some extent, I understand
why some would be skittish.
But you have to
have the foresight
to see where your
industry is going,
whether that's a sport
or a business or what,
and just sort of, on some level,
take it on faith that it's
going to pay off in the end.
DAVID BARRY: So covering
the team for as long
as you did, having spent
a lot of time with them,
could you talk a little
bit about the players?
ERIK MALINOWSKI: They
are agonizingly normal.
For the amount of
success that they have,
you would assume that--
I mean you can look
at a guy like Draymond
Green and his bluster.
I mean that's just
his character.
I mean that's just who he is.
He's not like that--
DAVID BARRY: Controversial.
ERIK MALINOWSKI: --all the time.
What's that?
DAVID BARRY: Controversial.
ERIK MALINOWSKI: Yeah.
But that's the role
that he has to play.
He understands that that's--
when other guys aren't
going to speak up,
he's going to be the
guy that speaks up.
So if there's an
archetype on the team,
that's the role that he plays.
Again, they've experience so
much success over the years,
but they still are able to
have these moments, where--
I remember one game last season
where the Charlotte Hornets
came into town.
And so Steph Curry's
dad, Del Curry, who
played 16 years in the
NBA, he was very much
a guy like Steve Kerr, shot the
three balls, a super sixth man.
But so he's an announcer
for the Charlotte Hornets,
and so there was a time after
that game in the locker room,
where--
and understand that the
Warriors are, basically, again,
at the top of the
NBA, and basically
rolling to another championship,
their second in three years.
And you can have a moment,
where Del Curry basically
walks into the locker room.
He's got his backpack on.
He's in full dad mode, and he
walks up to Steph's locker,
and there's nobody
standing, basically,
within 10 feet of them.
And they're just having
a quiet conversation.
I couldn't tell you what
they were talking about,
because nobody was standing
close enough to listen.
But to have that sort of
private sort of intimate moment
between a father and a son
and just the idea that people
would sort of--
you're in a position, where
that can sort of still
happen with this team.
I feel like this team,
in time, sort of may--
I think they're
well on their way
to their pantheon
in the all-time NBA
and this conversation of
the all-time great teams.
But they still value personal--
just the atmosphere
and the chemistry.
And to have a locker
room and a clubhouse,
where a dad can come in
and just sort of talk
to his son for a few
minutes, it doesn't
matter that the son is Steph
Curry, one of the top three
megastars on the planet, that
this is an environment where
that can still happen.
I think that maybe in
two or three years,
maybe that's not going
to be feasible anymore.
Maybe everyone's star is
just going to be so much,
or the atmosphere
is going to be such
that we're not going to be able
to see those moments anymore.
But I'll say that for
this moment in time,
the Warriors have put themselves
in a position, where they
can still have those
moments, where they still
value that sort of normalcy.
We'll see if that lasts
another two or three years,
but for now, that's indicative
of where this organization is.
And I think in a lot of ways,
that works to their benefit
and explains how they've
been so successful.
But now they're in
a position where
they can keep the success
going for a few more years.
DAVID BARRY: So what was it
like to cover the last three
finals, the two wins, of course,
but also the tragic, tragic
loss?
ERIK MALINOWSKI: Up and down
and up, I guess you could say.
Well, I should say I'm not
a lifelong Warriors fan.
I'm a Knicks fan, actually,
for 20 years or so.
So in some senses,
that helped writing
the first couple of
chapters of the book,
because I have a lot of
experience writing about poorly
run inept franchises with
the Warriors-- team owners
that you just wish
would just go away,
and literally anyone else
would come in to buy the team.
But yeah, it's been an
experience seeing the crowds
and seeing the level
of success they've had.
I will say that right up until--
I was in Oracle Arena
for that game seven,
that gutting loss
in June of 2016,
when they lost on the
Kyrie Irving three.
But it was really weird.
Right up until that point,
for all of the failures
that they had for
all those years,
with this new
iteration of the team,
it was you just didn't think
that anything bad like that
was going to happen.
You just didn't
think that they were
going to lose at the moment,
where they could least
afford to do so.
And it happened, and it
really just showed you
that no matter what
level of success
you have, no matter
what you've built up,
you're just sort of
privy to the basketball
gods or a vengeful sort.
And you just never
know what they're going
to decide on any given day.
And those sorts of thing--
and a historic collapse,
the kind of which we've
never seen before can happen.
It doesn't matter if
you won 73 games or not.
But it was fascinating
then to see
an organization that had been
basically publicly humiliated.
They became an internet meme,
basically, in and of itself,
blowing a 3-1 lead.
This has become
part of the lexicon.
It's become part of
the vernacular now.
But to see them pick
themselves up from that,
and of course, I think
signing Kevin Durant does
a lot for the healing process.
But it wasn't just as simple
as sending Kevin Durant.
It was about-- in some
ways, it was almost
about this idea of
steering into the skid.
You know what I mean?
Like almost in some ways,
embracing the failure,
not being afraid of it,
not running from it.
You know, I went to the Warriors
at a very sort of delicate time
in this process and
told them, basically,
that I was going to write
this book on you guys,
and you can sort of be
involved to whatever extent.
Obviously, they can
make my life easier,
or they can make it harder.
They didn't make my life
easy, but at the same time,
they didn't obstruct.
And they literally
said those words--
we're not going to
make this hard for you.
And I really appreciated
that, because I
think that sort of did come at
a very sort of critical time
in my reporting for the book.
But at the same time, they
made it very clear to me
that we don't want to seem like
we're puffing our chest out
in any way or taunting
people, or now
we're the team that's
getting a book written
about them, that sort of thing.
And this was all, again, all
in the wake of the Kevin Durant
signing.
But if you fast forward
a few months later,
they're literally selling
Super Villains t-shirts
in their team store.
So they are embracing
this persona.
They are now, in
fact, profiting off
of this persona
and this backlash,
and so I think that
just comes from taking
a step back and understanding
that this is the reality.
This is what has befallen us,
and we can either run from it,
or we can embrace it.
And I think they decided that
they were going to embrace it.
And I think-- and then you
saw what happened last year.
They had some
periods of adversity.
Kevin Durant got
injured pretty late
in the season, sprained
his knee ligament.
They lost-- I think it was
like five out of seven games
or something like that.
And then they wound up
winning 14 games in a row.
And then he came back at
the end of the season,
and we all know what
happened with the playoffs.
But this was a team that
put itself in a position,
where we're not going to run
from any sort of adversity.
We're going to meet it
head on, and in some ways,
it definitely sort of helped the
book become a little bit more
interesting.
It certainly made for a more
interesting ending to it.
But that's just who they
are, and that's just what,
I think, again, that was
sort of indicative of what
they've built up over
the last few years here.
DAVID BARRY: And
speaking of the playoffs,
we're going to take
some audience questions
in just another minute or so.
But speaking of the playoffs,
we have seen with the league,
talent has gotten
concentrated in a few teams.
And you mentioned how
after the lockout,
there were things done to
try and address this issue,
yet you still see like
in the Kevin Durant
move to the Warriors, how it
seems like this there's still
a tendency for this to happen.
So what's your thought on that?
ERIK MALINOWSKI: Yeah,
this was something
that we saw with
the 2011 lockout,
which some of the things
that resulted from that
were a direct response
to LeBron James going
to Miami in the summer
of 2010 and the decision
and all of that and as a
response to this allowing teams
to create super
teams or whatever.
And so the idea is
that you're just
going to try to entice them
now more to sort of stay
with their own teams.
You offer more years, more
money, that sort of thing.
But with the Warriors,
it was just--
I mean in some ways, they
were just a product--
in a lot of ways,
the timing was good,
and their fortune was good.
The idea that Steph is going to
have all these ankle injuries
in such a way that it's
going to depress his market
value that he can sign
a four-year $44 million
contract, when by all rights,
he probably should have signed
something a lot more.
We saw right after he
signed that contract,
he sort of took his
game to a new level.
But lot of it was good
fortune, but they also
put themselves in a position
to maximize their good fortune.
It was about-- it's not lucky to
have a guy like Draymond Green
take a several million dollar
haircut on his new contract
extension.
It's not lucky to bring in a
guy like Shaun Livingston, who
has never really played his
full potential in the NBA.
I mean Andre Iguodala did not--
when he signed his
four-year deal before,
it was not for
below market rate.
So it was just about
certain pieces of the puzzle
coming together
at the right time.
It was not-- is not
something that you can really
legislate out of the
NBA, and so that's
why I'm really hesitant
when people say, oh,
can they just read the book?
And so what the Warriors
did-- is it a blueprint
for other teams to follow?
I don't think you can.
I don't think that they could--
you can't just follow
steps A through Z and say,
if you do these things, this
is how you build a super team.
But there are concepts that
you can apply to your team
to put yourself in
a better position
to take advantage of
certain moments of luck
and good fortune and
things like that.
But yeah, that's why it was
always-- it was this thing,
especially after they signed
Kevin Durant, it was like,
oh, we've got to change
something in the CBA
to prevent this sort of
thing from happening.
But it's not really
something you
can legislate out of the NBA.
I call it competitive imbalance.
But it's the idea that I never
understood when people say--
to me, it's like
the larger issue
is that not that the Warriors
themselves are scooping up
all of this talent.
I think it's easy
to look at them
and say, oh, they've got
these four superstars.
We have to institute something
to prevent this in the future.
But to me, in some ways, I
would say the bigger issue
is you have the teams right
below them, who already
do have a lot of talent.
And they're now the
ones that are trying
to scoop up this elite talent.
And so it's not about the
Warriors getting this talent.
It's about a team like
Houston going out,
and they've already got
a guy like James Harden,
but now they worked
this mega trade,
and they bring in a
guy like Chris Paul.
And you look at that sort
of in an objective way,
and you think, there's
really no sense in having
a guy like James Harden
and a guy like Chris Paul,
these high usage guys, who
are used to running offenses.
And there's almost no--
and so now it just
becomes a talent grab.
And now it's just like--
in some ways, it's a
little bit of desperation
when you have
teams saying, well,
we just need to close
that talent gap in any way
that we can.
So you have a team
like Oklahoma City
that goes out of its way to
bring in a guy like Carmelo
Anthony and to bring in a guy
like Paul George, who both Melo
and Paul George may not be there
after this year or whatever.
So it's extremely risky
on them, but they're
in a position,
where they just have
to do something to try
to close this talent gap.
So to me, I think
that's where you end up
seeing more of the imbalance.
It's not just with the Warriors,
but all these other sort
of tier one teams--
they're trying to compete.
Maybe it's going to make
things more interest come
the end of the Western
Conference playoffs,
but you really are diluting
all of these other teams.
And so I think that whenever
these mega super teams will
play each other, I think those
games will be more interesting,
perhaps, than they've been
in the last one or two years.
But I think it's going to
make the rest of the NBA
really suffer, because
now you've diluted
the rest of that talent pool.
DAVID BARRY: Yeah, the
James Harden and Chris Paul
sounds a little bit
like the Warriors,
like the Steph Curry
and Monta Ellis.
ERIK MALINOWSKI: Right.
Exactly.
I mean that was a case, where--
yeah, I get to that in a
lot of detail in the book.
But yeah, that was a case,
where we've basically
got two guys that are
almost the same physically.
They basically play
the same position.
They bring a lot of the same
game, but we have to decide.
In the Warriors case
there, they decided
to trade the guy who was
the fan favorite, who
was the most tenured Warrior.
But yeah, he was
the oldest player.
But they realized
that we're going
to have to take this
backlash, because he's
stunting Steph's development.
He's also stunting Klay
Thompson's development
to some extent.
And you saw that once
they traded away Monta,
Klay Thompson started all
those rest of the games
the rest of the season,
as I say in the book.
And that was really what brought
his development on track,
so it wasn't even just
about helping Steph.
It was about helping Klay.
But yeah, in some ways, it's
like the reverse Monta Ellis,
because now you've got
guys-- and so I'm not
the most optimist-- we can look
back at this in a few months
and see how Houston's
season turned out.
And I think in a
small sample size,
I think against the Warriors,
their games against them
will be more competitive.
But it's not just about the
games against the Warriors.
It's about playing
a whole season.
It's about creating the right
kind of chemistry and coherence
with your team.
So in some sense, I'll be really
interested to see how Houston
turns out, because I don't
think it's a guarantee at all
that they're going to just
bring in a guy like Chris Paul,
and things are going to
automatically improve.
And I think that's what
I saw with the Warriors
over the years was
it was just about
you have the money,
so you're going to try
to bring in the most talent.
But is it the right
kind of talent?
And that was a
mistake the Warriors
made for a lot of years, right
up until this new ownership
came in.
DAVID BARRY: OK, I know you
touched on this already,
but I wanted to
expand a little bit.
The most common criticism of the
Warriors is, well, the only way
they keep winning is--
the only reason
they keep winning
is they have all this
generational talent, i.e.
Steph Curry, Kevin Durant.
To that, what do you say?
ERIK MALINOWSKI: I say that's
a really big part of it.
And I just want to
make it really clear,
and I hope that
people read the book,
and they come away
thinking that I'm
trying to minimize the
importance of talent,
because obviously, that is the
biggest part of the equation
here.
And this isn't like--
in some ways, with
"Moneyball," it
was like it was a
matter of resources.
And they really
just couldn't go out
and get the right
kind of talent.
So the way that they were going
to the market inefficiency,
and they were going to
try to exploit it was
try to get guys that
were undervalued
and could get on base and
all these sorts of things.
And these aren't problems.
The Warriors-- obviously,
they have resources,
and they have been allowed
to invest over the years.
But for me, it's been
about understanding--
and this is why I basically
spend the first couple
of chapters of the book laying
out the more recent history
and Steph's rookie year and what
the previous ownership group
was and just how bad
the Warriors have been,
because I think you have to
understand just how far--
just how bad they were,
I mean just how truly,
truly terrible they were.
And I think that once you
understand that, you understand
not that just that they have
gone from some middling team
to an elite team, but that they
have gone from a historically
awful team to a team that's
literally doing things
that we've never seen
do before in the NBA.
And so I think that if it
were something like this, then
I think talent would be--
then I think it
would be something,
where you could
look at the talent
and say, oh, this is
more of the factor that
is going to rule the day.
But the idea that
the gap is just
so wide between where they
were and where they are now,
that there's just so much more
that goes into that equation
and that there is
more complexity to it,
and there's so many
other factors at play,
and that it is more nuanced
than just saying it is a Steph
or it is a Klay.
So I hope that's
one of the big--
I hope that's one
of the takeaways.
I think that it's a common
frustration of mine when
I see people sort of take the
argument in those directions,
because I'm like, no,
no, no, step back.
Read the book.
It's really just about
so much more than that.
But I understand people's
tendency to go in that dir--
I don't begrudge
them in any way,
because I do think that that's
a pretty common misconception.
DAVID BARRY: OK,
well, I think we'll
take some audience questions.
AUDIENCE: So when I
think of "Moneyball,
I think of Billy
Beane finding ways
to find new players,
undervalued,
and generate wins that way.
But from the talk
and what I anticipate
in the book is that betaball--
how you view it is more
about than just using
data and finding
ways to generate ways
of using data to help you win.
It sounds like it's
more of the ethos
of the organization as a whole.
And with the
"Moneyball" piece, it
seems like over the years,
that competitive edge has
sort of disappeared a
lot, because everyone
started doing it.
ERIK MALINOWSKI: Right.
DAVID BARRY: So
are there elements
that you find that are
maybe slowly disappearing
through those methods
that are disappearing?
And what are maybe
some of the things that
are unique to the Golden
State Warriors that
are going to be very hard to
replicate across other teams?
ERIK MALINOWSKI: Yeah, I
think what you're seeing
is that in terms of--
I always say in terms of
data-driven analytics.
I think those are the
sorts of places where we've
seen the playing field level.
I think it's been
easier for teams
to sort of catch up
along those lines.
I think it's going to be--
it's going to be in sort of
the areas that are a little bit
more parallel to sports.
I brought up before about
monitoring players' sleep
patterns and things like that.
I mean it's going to be the
things that a lot of teams
look at and say--
maybe they're not willing
to go that extra mile
or just look at that
aspect of sports
or to understand, how
does this actually work?
How can we apply this,
practically speaking,
in a basketball sense?
Those are the places that
the Warriors are starting
to look at, and it's also
things like virtual reality
and things like that, and it's
about trying to understand,
are there ways to
play basketball
that are more efficient?
Are there concepts-- it's
about, are there ways
that we can improve our
practice and training regimen?
And is that going to help our
team excel in some way that,
perhaps, other teams aren't?
And I just think
that they really
sort of value their geography.
I think that it would be really
easy for some organization
to sort of be here and say
that, we're going to do things
our way, or we're going to
keep things proprietary,
that sort of thing.
But they don't look at
that as competition.
They really look at
it as collaboration.
And so that's why
I think they like
to work with a lot of
these third parties,
and they don't expect that
any of these partnerships
are going to necessarily
change the moon and the stars.
But they understand
that if there
are ways that they can
incrementally get better, then
they're going to do that.
And at this point,
all the time--
they don't really
have a lot more room
to improve at this point,
which in some ways,
makes the equation a little bit
harder, not about motivation,
but practically speaking,
how much better can you get?
You've had a team
that won 73 games.
Are they going to
go 74 wins now?
I mean I don't think anyone
really expects them to do that.
I don't think that
they look at it--
I think they've stopped
looking at basketball sort
of in a micro sense
and sort of, how
can we change this little
thing and that little thing?
I think that they're looking
at it in a more long term macro
sense and understanding that
their place in basketball
history, the discussion of
the all-time great teams,
their place in that
discussion is--
it is still unwritten.
I mean we don't know what the
ending is for this franchise
and this organization.
And I think they're
understanding
that a lot of this can come
crashing down pretty quickly.
I think these things always
rise up faster than we think,
and they can kind of end
faster than we think.
Even though we feel
like the Warriors have
been good for so
long, they've only
been elite for three years.
They've only made
the playoffs-- you'll
get a team like the
Spurs, who've made
the playoffs 20 years in a row.
What is it?
18 straight years
of 50 wins or more.
The Warriors-- their
playoff streak at the moment
is only five years.
So this thing is
pretty ephemeral,
but at the same time,
these things can burn fast,
and they can burn
out pretty quickly.
So I think they understand
that in some ways,
it really is up to them
what direction this goes.
Are they going to be
a team like the Spurs?
Are they going to
be a team that--
are they going to turn
over their roster?
Is that going to be how they
hold their advantage now
is going to be a
Spursian kind of, well,
we're just going to be
consistently excellent,
and we're going to have a
puncher's chance every year
of winning a championship.
Or do they go like
full Jordan era bulls,
where they try to win
six titles in eight years
or whatever it was?
And now you look at
the Bulls, they're
probably the worst team
in the NBA talent-wise.
But they had their
run of success.
They had their
impact on the NBA,
and no one's ever going to
take that away from them.
But what do they want to be?
Do they want to be the team
that burns fast and burns out?
Or do they want to create
something that is more lasting?
I think at this point in
time, if you were to guess,
they're trying to do the latter.
They're trying to see more of
that Spursian kind of model.
But like I said, things can
change so quickly in the NBA.
Sometimes we don't know
where that next innovation
is going to come from.
I think that they
think and they hope
that they're going to be the
ones to embrace that, whatever
it might be.
But these things
can be unexpected.
So you just never
know sometimes.
DAVID BARRY: Are you bullish?
ERIK MALINOWSKI: I am bullish.
I think that you can't help but
sort of look at what they've
done these last three to
five years and seven years
since the owners have come
in, but to look at them
and say that--
it's clear that there's
more at play here
than just getting
in talented guys,
that there is an effect that the
front office and the coaching
staff has that they have
an important role to play,
and that as long as you keep, if
not those same people in power
and making decisions, but
similar people that just
embrace that sort of
mindset and that philosophy.
Maybe it's not a
guy like Steve Kerr,
but it's one of his disciples,
or it's some part of the Steve
Kerr coaching tree.
Or we just saw Jerry
West left this summer.
He left, and now he's
gone to the LA Clippers
to be an advisor for them.
Now, you're going to
see other guys that--
Kirk Lacob is going
to have a larger role
to say in the organization.
You're going to go see a guy
like Larry Harris, who is not
maybe sort of a household
name to a lot of these guys,
but he's going to have a
bigger role to play now.
And he's been a guy that's
been around a few years.
So you're going to have--
now you're going
to start to see,
as success breeds
more defections,
and people want a piece
of what the Warriors have,
and they start--
like I said, Travis
Schlenk, who has
been the worst for 13 years.
Now he's the general manager
of the Atlanta Hawks.
Now that he's trying
to change them
in a way that he's learned,
not only under this ownership,
but he was a holdover from
the previous ownership.
So this is a guy who
knows not what to do,
but also what not to do.
But you're going to
have these guys start
to impart these
lessons across the NBA,
and so the onus is going to be
on the Warriors to bring in--
to keep that going, to bring
in guys that understand that,
to keep creating the next
generation of NBA executives.
And I think, in
some ways, that's
a lot easier said than done.
But based on their most
recent track record,
it's hard to bet against them.
DAVID BARRY: Well, thank
you, Mr. Malinowski.
Let's give him one
more round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]